jour vous êtes ancien chef d'état-major
de l'armée de l'air ancien commandant
suprême allié de la transformation de
l'OTAN merci à vous de répondre à France
24 on va écouter peut-être pour
commencer le numéro un de l'otanian
stoltonberg qui promet un message clair
et positif à l'Ukraine dans la
perspective donc d'une adhésion
lors de ce sommet nous allons prendre
des décisions importantes en envoyant un
message clair à l'Ukraine nous nous
tenons à ses côtés aussi longtemps qu'il
le faudra et nous attendons de nos
alliés qu'il réitère leur engagement à
fournir un soutien militaire à l'Ukraine
pour l'aider à libérer davantage de
territoires
même chez pêcheurs en ce qui concerne la
question de l'adhésion je m'attends
également à ce que les Alliés envoient
un message clair et positifs sur la voie
à suivre pour l'adhésion de l'Ukraine
un message clair et positif on attend
donc le communiqué il y aura pas de
calendrier dévoilé des Washington dans
la perspective d'une adhésion qu'elle
pourrait être la bonne formule selon
vous
la bonne formule ça sera de d'abord de
gérer le court terme parce que ça reste
l'essentiel tout dépendra de l'issue de
cette guerre on peut prendre tous les
paris et on peut s'engager sur la voie
et ça va être indiqué ainsi d'une future
adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'OTAN mais tout
dépendra du sort et de l'issue de cette
guerre qui sera qui sera déterminé par
les armes donc ce sommeil doit traiter
le court terme bien s'assurer du soutien
des pays alliés d'ailleurs je souligne
que ce que vient d'annoncer le président
Macron qu'on avait déjà prévu qu'en
quelque sorte la livraison de missile
scale ce sont des missiles je tiens à le
préciser airsol donc pour aller frapper
des cibles avec une grande précision ils
sont tirés à partir d'avions de combat
donc comme les Storm Shadow c'est à peu
près le même système je ferme cette
parenthèse mais c'est vraiment une
contribution extrêmement utile que fait
la France aux côtés de la en Bretagne
pour aller frapper ses objectifs à
profondeur je ferme cette parenthèse
donc pour le long terme ce qui est
important finalement c'est tracer une
voie une voie d'avenir bon que le
président zenenski montre certaines
énervement ça fait partie un peu du jeu
diplomatique si vous voulez il peut pas
partir comme ça venir l'OTAN et dire je
suis satisfait un jour l'Ukraine lui
évidemment je pense que ce qu'il en tête
il a pas forcément tort c'est que
l'Ukraine dès que la situation le
permettra et ça c'est un vrai une vraie
question quand et comment doit pouvoir
adhérer très rapidement à l'OTAN c'est
ça l'enjeu c'est à dire faire en sorte
que tout le processus soit déjà préparé
et puis que le jour J
l'Ukraine soit accueilli dans l'OTAN un
peu comme on l'a fait avec la Finlande
et la Suède où il y avait eu des travaux
préparatoires j'ai participé très avancé
et le jour où la fin de la Suède ont
décidé de vouloir proposer leur
candidature ça a été relativement rapide
donc il faut absolument faire la même
chose parce que cette période de
transition au moment où s'arrêtera on
s'arrêteront les combats elle peut être
instable et il faudra stabiliser c'est
mon avis en tout cas stabiliser la
situation l'Ukraine le plus vite
possible donc excusez-moi mais pour que
les choses soient bien clair l'Ukraine
sera un jour membre de l'OTAN mais ça
sera forcément après la guerre
ça ne peut pas être pendant la guerre
monsieur zeninski il a parfaitement
compris ça a été rappelé par Armelle
charrier vous API en guerre ne peut pas
rentrer dans une alliance dont le
principe même est d'éviter la guerre et
éventuellement de s'engager
collectivement si l'un des pays est
attaqué or ce pays est attaqué en ce
moment vous voyez bien l'incohérence de
ce dispositif nous ne voulons pas être
collé les gens en Ukraine nous ne
voulons pas faire directement la guerre
à la Russie ce n'est pas pour accueillir
l'Ukraine et ensuite être obligé quel
que sort de s'engager ça serait aberrant
et c'est vraiment ce qui a voulu
signifier en particulier le président
Biden il a été très clair sur ce sujet
et relativement prudente et je pense que
c'est normal mais ça veut pas dire que
la porte est ouverte est fermée
là il y a pas un risque si l'Ukraine
n'entre pas pendant la guerre il y a pas
un risque que la Russie finalement
prolonge la guerre pour que Kiev n'entre
pas dans l'OTAN
bien sûr bien sûr on a on a eu une
situation un peu similaire au début de
la guerre froide là quand Staline a
poussé vers l'Est bon il se trouve que
la situation s'est stabilisée et que
l'Allemagne a pu rentrer très rapidement
très rapidement dans le temps
l'Allemagne fédérale à l'époque il
faudra saisir le moment c'est ça l'enjeu
c'est comment comment va tourner le sort
des arbres il faudra le moment positif
mais il faudra aussi aller très vite
parce évidemment c'est évident monsieur
Poutine ou son successeur la Russie ne
laissera pas faire les choses essaiera
de pourrir en quelque sorte la situation
comme elle l'a fait en Géorgie comme
elle l'a fait en 2014 en attaquant
l'Ukraine en 2014 la Russie ça fait
pertinemment qu'elle mettait
complètement en jeu la candidature de
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN et la rendait
impossible
parlons donc du court terme puisque
c'est ce qui nous anime avec cette
guerre qui a dépassé les 500 jours
est-ce qu'on pourrait imaginer une forme
de partenariat
Ukraine autant il y a demain je crois
une réunion une première réunion Ukraine
autant avec volodièreski un peu sur le
modèle d'Israël avec les États-Unis
alors l'OTAN n'est pas les États-Unis le
temps n'a pas vocation à fournir en tant
que tel
un soutien enfin des armements ce sont
les paix qui décident de le faire et là
en l'occurrence les États-Unis pour
Israël donc président
a ouvert cette voie et ça sera utile
parce qu'il faudra continuer à armer
l'Ukraine y compris d'ailleurs après la
guerre pour qu'elle soit tout à fait
souvienne qu'elle parle qu'elle prenne
sa part pleine et entière à l'alliance
et ça sera un pays ça sera pas un
fardeau l'Ukraine pour l'Alliance ce
sera un pays contributeur de paix de
sécurité lorsqu'elle sera stabilisée
donc voilà
après il faut trouver les moyens pour
que effectivement le soutien des alliés
reste indéfectible et qu'il puisse
amener ce qu'ils veulent en voile tout
le problème des munitions c'est terrible
ce décalage entre ce que nous sommes
capables et y compris les États-Unis de
fournir je pense aux obus de 155 par
exemple et ce que consomme aujourd'hui
les Ukrainiens sur le terrain
pratiquement obligé ils sont obligés de
se freiner dans l'utilisation alors que
les Russes consomment sans compter
comptant sans doute sur leur industrie
pour fournir ce dont ils ont besoin ça
ça reste une une question qui est posée
lorsqu'il me concerne mais il est
certain que voilà pour l'instant sur le
court terme c'est surtout ne pas se
désengager et avoir cette perspective et
justement à quel point cette
contre-offensive qui a été lancée il y a
à peu près un mois maintenant par le
crâne influence les choix les
positionnements des membres de l'OTAN en
quoi est-elle décisive
évidemment chacun il y a une certaine
impatience c'est assez logique on
aimerait bien tous que que cette guerre
évidemment se terminer rapidement que
l'Ukraine recouvre sa souveraineté mais
malheureusement elle a en face d'elle
l'armée alors dans l'armée russe c'est
pas rien la Russie l'armée russe qui
s'est préparée dans des positions
défensives donc il faut il faut laisser
du temps au temps monsieur Zelinski ne
peut pas ne peut pas sacrifier les
hommes et des femmes malheureuses il le
sait il est comptable de tout ça donc il
faut laisser du temps il faut bien
étudier avec lui ses besoins il faut
anticiper ses besoins et ça c'est
vraiment fondamental on parle des
munitions on parle des pièces de
rechange il y a tout un débat aussi là
dessus sur la qualité des équipements
qui sont fournis on sait que certains
équipements qui sont fournis sont
défectueux à leur origine qu'il faut
améliorer tout ça il faut vraiment que
notre soutien soit à la fois quantitatif
et qualitatif auprès l'Ukraine et ça
c'est la première étape à franchir si
cette première étape n'est pas franchie
il n'y aura pas de seconde étape il n'y
aura pas de d'Ukraine dans l'OTAN donc
il faut que l'Ukraine quelque part gagne
sa souveraineté on verra bien dans
quelle frontière mais qu'elle gagne sa
souveraineté merci infiniment Jean-Paul
palomer